welcome
to I'm
here and and what Mom you think I'll
just be sitting here waiting for someone
to bring him
[Applause]
home that it
this is my
father what do you want can you tell us
anything we have been waiting let's just
forget this happened are you kidding me
you flew halfway around the world
looking for something then all you found
was dad was apparently a lying I want to
show you something he just wasn't who
you say he was got to give it to the guy
he had two families and still had time
to be obsessed with work it was
important do you even know what he
did
hey what's in here I didn't know it was
[Music]
there they were there in San Francisco
like soldiers or something with this
on their uniforms you think that your
father was working for them this stuff
wasn't a safe she wants to know if he
was with you when it happened was he
with you what difference does that make
now you don't think it would have made a
difference if he'd been here with us
instead no he wasn't with
[Music]
me about a week after that we got a call
from the state police iner ANS Alaska
saying the bush plan here was on disapp
appeared in a storm they never found the
wreckage what are youall going to do
[Music]
now
Colonel
Shaw you want to find out what happened
to my father now you can choke down that
mountain of Monarch about your father
disappearing Without a Trace or we can
get the hell out of here right now and
find out what really happened with your
dad did our dad really work for them for
Monarch it is your family business it's
not our family business it's the family
curse
go
run come
on I got
you come on hurry let's
go
go they said the signal was so weak they
almost didn't hear me on the emergency
Channel I never thought I'd thank
someone for abandoning their family but
here we are scribble down every crazy
thing he came across till his pencils
were nothing but Nubs dad did that yeah
he' sharpened them with the pen knife
that he carried left the shavings
everywhere I know that
handwriting me
too he
survived Monarch may know how to find
the Titans but they don't know how to
find
dad do we I already searched his office
not the one in San Francisco dad would
sing these cheesy
commercials San
Francisco
Alaska Africa this must be the path he
took
is
[Music]
that he's
alive
dad over here Dad
Dad
Dad up here
we got to get out of there come on we
got to move now now move we need to go
now guar we got to
go
[Applause]
[Music]